look at them in their Maga hats look at
them with their white Vans and their
Flags Let's uh shift over a little bit
to something that happened during Co
that illustrates exactly uh what Russell
is talking about perfectly uh you may
remember this I think we played this
once during Co this is an Australian ad
so an Australian ad from the government
scare the hell out of people during
covid now remember he was talking about
how these the guys will have nice
quaffed hair and the women will speak
really nicely as they're pushing you
towards authoritarianism what's the
easiest way to do that scare people and
then they will do it to
[Music]
themselves authorized by the Australian
government CA authorized by this a
Australian government Canberra I mean
you see the type of fear right I could
play four gajillion videos roughly of
how they did that to all of us six feet
social distance all of this nonsense
right only so many people can go into a
store at a time people yelling at each
other over masks and all of those things
but they were doing it for you right and
that's the distinction he's trying to
make that's very different than a bunch
of Nazi foot soldiers walking into town
and and you know murdering people and
everything else that's kind of the way
we think of that authoritarianism right
the boot on the neck they're going to
come in and someone's going to be a
little bit different and they'll just
kill them there might be something a
little more subtle that they're doing
and it's kind of a thing that that
they've done in almost every dystopian
sci-fi movie bit more from Russell on
how the intellectual class the very same
people who were telling you to do all
these things that didn't work and get
injected with stuff and all that uh they
don't really care about you weird wild
stuff there's no question that I rise in
uh
nationalism is an understandable
response to rampant globalism but the
ongoing sort of finger pointing and
condemnation of ordinary people I
identify with I recognize it because I
grew up in those communities
professional met Metropolitan people
don't like workingclass people don't
like Ordinary People and now they've
found a way to legitimize their hatred
oh they're all disgusting they're all
racist look at them in their Maga hats
look at them with their white Vans and
their flags look at them with their
perspective Ives with their unearned
views and their belches and their beer
it's a kind of legitimization of a
loathing of the people that are most
connected to the nation people that
generally speaking a couple of
generations ago were asked to sacrifice
the lives of their sons and daughters
for the for the idea of nation an idea
that they're now being told doesn't
exist
yeah yeah and we're going to illustrate
some of that uh after this ad in just a
second but I I do want to note that it's
important when you see two guys like
that sitting down in America today and I
keep talking about how these you know
it's not really left vers right anymore
and it's mostly it's most it's mostly
authoritarian vers libertarian and I
don't mean you're a card carrying
shellack member of the libertarian party
uh but it's do you believe in
centralized Authority which of course
lends itself to globalism and that there
really won't be nation states they'll be
sort of the world economic Forum layer
and they'll have their yearly meetings
and they'll tell the Nations what to do
and a lot of people will just say thank
you sir may I have another or do you
believe in more of a Libertarian outlook
on life which would lead to functioning
nation states which is what we've had
basically for the last hundred or so
years uh and that you would make some
choices over your life and and that
really is what the Divide is but there
is there seemingly is a disdain remember
when we showed you a bunch of those
videos from the world economic Forum
last week and you see these people John
car is the easiest one to talk about who
flies on a private jet all the time you
also may remember what was it two months
ago testifying under oath that he didn't
have a private jet and then when he was
question further oh it turned out to be
his wife's private jet so they want all
of the stuff they will eat their
Japanese A5 wagu they will eat their
fagra and then they will have you eating
lab grown meat and all of the rest of it
right that is the
disconnect